o entrelaçamento quântico permite que partículas sejam conectadas independentemente do espaço entre elas — isso é tão contraintuitivo
que até Einstein não acreditava que fosse verdade. No episódio de hoje do Qiskit na Sala de Aula, vamos falar sobre como o teorema de Bell
provou que Einstein
estava errado. Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na Sala de Aula. Nesta série, vamos usar o Qiskit para explorar alguns conceitos fundamentais comumente
abordados em cursos relacionados à Computação Quântica. Cada vídeo também será acompanhado de um módulo interativo
com link na descrição abaixo, então não deixa de conferir. No vídeo das moedas quânticas, discutimos como medir uma
superposição quântica é um processo inerentemente probabilístico, como jogar uma moeda — em certos aspectos. Mas como sabemos
disso? Será que uma partícula quântica esconde secretamente um resultado predeterminado de uma medição, mas de alguma forma não conseguimos
capturar essa informação na nossa teoria? Nos primórdios da mecânica quântica, essa questão era tema
de debate acalorado, com dois grupos principais. Em um campo estava Einstein, que acreditava que a mecânica quântica era incompleta,
ou seja, que faltavam algumas variáveis necessárias para descrever completamente um sistema. Einstein achava que
essas chamadas variáveis ocultas, se encontradas, resolveriam alguns dos aspectos aparentemente paradoxais e probabilísticos
da mecânica quântica. No outro campo estava Max Born. Born argumentava
que a descrição probabilística fornecida pela mecânica quântica é tudo o que a natureza especifica — em outras palavras,
não é apenas que não sabemos o estado de uma partícula antes de medi-la; é que a partícula não tem um estado definido
antes de ser medida. Durante décadas, muitos acharam que essa discordância era uma questão filosófica que talvez jamais
fosse resolvida. Afinal, para aprender qualquer coisa sobre um sistema, precisamos medi-lo. Como podemos aprender
alguma coisa sobre a natureza de um estado antes de medi-lo? Então, em 1964, o físico
John Bell encontrou um caminho. Em seu artigo, Bell examinou as correlações estatísticas entre medições de um par de
partículas entrelaçadas. Se, antes da medição, os estados das partículas fossem determinados por algumas variáveis ocultas desconhecidas,
Bell descobriu que suas correlações tinham um limite superior. Por outro lado, quando calculou as
correlações previstas pela mecânica quântica, percebeu que elas violavam esse limite. Então ele havia encontrado uma forma de, de uma vez
por todas, diferenciar a visão de Einstein da de Born. Só restava testar experimentalmente
essas correlações com partículas reais para ver se obedeciam às estatísticas de variáveis ocultas ou se
violavam essa regra. Esses testes foram realizados com precisão e sofisticação crescentes
ao longo dos anos e estão entre os experimentos mais significativos da física moderna. Foram tão revolucionários que
renderam o Prêmio Nobel a três físicos em 2022. Mas hoje em dia qualquer pessoa pode realizar um
teste de Bell. Tudo o que precisamos é um pouco de conhecimento do Qiskit e acesso a um computador quântico da IBM. Neste vídeo, vou
te guiar pela lógica da desigualdade de Bell e depois mostrarei como podemos testar as previsões de Bell num computador
quântico da IBM. A desigualdade de Bell envolve algumas medições e camadas de lógica diferentes, e pode ser um
pouco difícil de acompanhar, mas vamos passar por isso passo a passo e, no final, vai valer a pena. Estamos prestes a mostrar
que o entrelaçamento é real e que Einstein estava errado. Isso não é algo que muita gente pode dizer que fez. Então, eis
o que Bell propôs. Digamos que tu tenhas uma forma de produzir muitas cópias de um par entrelaçado de partículas. Fisicamente,
esses pares podem ser produzidos por um processo de decaimento, onde uma partícula se divide em duas. Se você assistiu ao vídeo sobre o
experimento de Stern-Gerlach, sabe que as partículas podem ter um momento angular intrínseco chamado
spin. Digamos que uma partícula de spin zero decai em duas partículas de spin 1/2.
Então cada uma das partículas de spin 1/2 pode ser medida com spin +1/2 ou spin −1/2,
também chamados de spin up ou spin down. Mas como elas decaíram de uma partícula de spin zero, as duas devem se combinar para
ter um spin total de zero também. Portanto, se uma for medida como up, a outra deve ser
down e vice-versa. Essas partículas formam um par entrelaçado que tem esta aparência.
Então, se uma for medida como up, a outra é down e vice-versa. Digamos que a partícula um voe para a esquerda, na direção
−X, onde um pesquisador que chamaremos de Lucas mede o seu
spin. Então a partícula dois voa de forma semelhante para a direita,
onde outra pesquisadora, Rihanna, pode medir esse spin. Lucas e Rihanna podem, de forma independente,
girar seus aparelhos de medição para escolher medir o spin de suas respectivas partículas em qualquer direção
perpendicular à direção de movimento da partícula. Se enviarmos muitas cópias do estado entrelaçado para Lucas
e Rihanna, eles podem coletar estatísticas de medição. Se sempre medirem ao longo do mesmo eixo, essas estatísticas não serão
muito interessantes: toda vez que um mede spin up, o outro mede spin down; e toda vez que um mede spin
para frente, o outro mede spin para trás; e assim por diante. Mas se os dois pesquisadores medirem ao longo de eixos diferentes, podemos encontrar
algo mais interessante. Vamos dar a Lucas e Rihanna três eixos ao longo dos quais
medir. Vamos chamar esses eixos de a, b e c, e eles são cada um separado por
120°. A pergunta que faremos com esse experimento é: se Lucas e Rihanna são livres para medir ao longo de qualquer um dos três
eixos, com que frequência os dois obterão o mesmo sinal? Claramente, se Lucas e Rihanna escolherem medir ao longo do mesmo eixo,
digamos o eixo a, eles nunca poderão obter o mesmo sinal, já que as partículas devem se combinar para ter spin zero. Mas quando escolhem
eixos diferentes, como suas medições serão correlacionadas, se é que serão? De acordo com Einstein, essa descrição quântica
do estado da partícula é incompleta. Ele achava que devem existir variáveis ocultas que
predeterminam o resultado de todas as medições de spin possíveis, pois, sem isso, partículas entrelaçadas teriam que
de alguma forma comunicar o resultado de sua medição umas às outras instantaneamente. Se uma fosse medida como
up bem lá, a outra teria que saber instantaneamente ser down
aqui. Essas variáveis ocultas poderiam ser qualquer conjunto complicado de instruções para o resultado dos experimentos, mas o ponto é
que o estado de spin de cada partícula separadamente é determinado, então nenhuma comunicação é necessária.
Experimentalmente, isso significaria que as medições feitas por Lucas não teriam nenhum efeito na partícula de Rihanna e vice-versa.
Isso poderia impor alguns limites ao grau de correlação entre as duas medições. Segundo Born, porém, esse estado
ψ é tudo o que se pode dizer sobre o par de partículas antes da medição, então a medição de uma partícula
afeta o resultado da medição da outra. Isso pode ter implicações diferentes para as correlações entre medições. Vamos ver como cada
teoria afeta essas correlações. No tratamento de variáveis ocultas, há um conjunto secreto de instruções antes da
medição que já determina o que Lucas medirá ao longo de cada um dos três eixos. Por exemplo, essas
instruções poderiam ser: positivo se Lucas medir ao longo do eixo a,
positivo se ele medir ao longo de b e negativo se medir ao longo de c. Podemos
escrever isso como +a, +b e −c. Então a partícula de Rihanna
precisaria ter as variáveis −a, −b e +c para garantir que o spin total
ao longo de qualquer direção única seja zero.
Há oito conjuntos de instruções possíveis que satisfazem essa restrição de spin zero, então cada vez que um novo par de
partículas é enviado a Lucas e Rihanna, ele pode conter qualquer um desses oito conjuntos de instruções. Então agora queremos
descobrir, assumindo que as partículas contêm um dos conjuntos secretos de instruções dados na tabela e
assumindo que Lucas e Rihanna escolhem independentemente qual dos três eixos medir, qual é a
probabilidade de ambos medirem o mesmo sinal? Se as instruções forem as dadas nas linhas 1 ou
8, então claramente essa probabilidade é zero, pois as duas partículas terão sinais opostos independentemente dos seus
eixos de medição. Mas e quanto às instruções da linha 2? Eles mediriam os mesmos sinais se
Rihanna medisse ao longo de c e Lucas medisse ao longo de a ou b, ou se Lucas
medisse ao longo de c e Rihanna medisse ao longo de a ou b. São quatro de cada nove das
combinações de medição possíveis que darão a Lucas e Rihanna o mesmo sinal. Se fizermos isso para
cada conjunto de instruções, verás que as linhas 3 a 7 também dão uma probabilidade de 4/9. Isso significa que, se
Einstein estiver certo e variáveis ocultas como essas predeterminem o resultado das medições, não há como Lucas
e Rihanna medirem o mesmo sinal com probabilidade maior que 4/9. Essa é a desigualdade de Bell: P ≤
4/9. E, como mostraremos, partículas entrelaçadas violam isso. Para
ver o que a mecânica quântica prevê, digamos que Lucas mede ao longo de a. Duas coisas podem acontecer: ou ele mede spin up, então
Rihanna mediria spin down ao longo de a, ou ele mede spin down e Rihanna mediria spin up ao longo de a. Mas
queremos a probabilidade de Rihanna medir o mesmo sinal que Lucas ao longo de qualquer eixo de sua escolha, não apenas a. Se
ela medir ao longo de b ou c, fica um pouco mais complicado. Acontece que,
se sabes o que Rihanna medirá com 100% de certeza ao longo de uma direção, podes calcular as probabilidades
de ela medir up ou down ao longo de qualquer outro eixo com um pouco de geometria.
Se o teu estado sempre mede spin up ao longo de um eixo, a probabilidade de medir spin up ao longo de um eixo diferente
será igual ao quadrado do cosseno de metade do ângulo entre os dois eixos. É um pouco complicado, mas
vou te mostrar o que quero dizer. Se Lucas mede spin up ao longo de a, sabemos com 100% de certeza que Rihanna mediria
spin down se fosse medir a. Podemos representar isso com um vetor
assim. Nesse caso, os ângulos entre esse vetor e os outros dois eixos de medição b e c são ambos
60°. Então metade disso é 30° e o cosseno de
30° é mostrado aqui. Cosseno ao quadrado de
30° = 3/4. Agora, e se Lucas mede spin down
ao longo de a? Sabemos que Rihanna mediria spin up ao longo de a, então podemos desenhar outro vetor aqui. Agora
esse vetor, que representa esse conhecimento, está a 120° de cada um dos outros dois eixos b
e c. Podemos fazer o mesmo truque geométrico, mas desta vez obteremos o cosseno de
60°. Então cosseno ao quadrado de
60° = 1/4. Como Lucas tem igual probabilidade de
medir spin up e spin down ao longo de a, precisamos fazer a média dessas duas probabilidades de Rihanna e chegamos a uma probabilidade final
de que Rihanna medirá o mesmo sinal que Lucas de 1/2. Então P
= 1/2. 1/2 é maior que 4/9, então a desigualdade de Bell é violada.
Isso significa que, enquanto as regras da mecânica quântica se mantiverem, variáveis ocultas são impossíveis. Agora podemos usar o Qiskit e um
computador quântico da IBM para testar a desigualdade de Bell com medições quânticas reais. Podemos mapear os estados spin up e
spin down das partículas de Lucas e Rihanna para os estados zero e um dos qubits no computador quântico. Vamos
usar dois qubits, um para representar a partícula de Lucas e outro para a de Rihanna, e entrelaçá-los com este circuit quântico.
Os dois qubits são representados pelos dois fios q0 e q1, e essa combinação
de gates X, Hadamard e CNOT criará o mesmo estado entrelaçado que tínhamos entre as partículas de Lucas e Rihanna. Agora
precisamos medir cada qubit. Vamos definir a medição de Lucas ao longo de a, que diremos ser o eixo Z. Já a medição de Rihanna
pode ser ao longo de a, b ou c, então precisaremos de três circuits separados para cada um desses três casos. Mas neste
vídeo faremos apenas um. Tu podes acessar o módulo com link na descrição para o conteúdo completo. Se Rihanna medir ao longo de
b, então o nosso circuit terá esta aparência, onde ry é uma rotação de 120° para mudar
o eixo de medição de Rihanna. Podemos usar o Sampler primitivo do Qiskit para executar esse experimento várias vezes e coletar
estatísticas das medições resultantes. As duas colunas, 00 e 11, representam os momentos em que Lucas e
Rihanna mediram o mesmo sinal, que é o que queremos. Então a probabilidade de medir as duas partículas com o
mesmo sinal é muito próxima de 1/2. Isso viola a desigualdade de Bell. Isso significa
que as duas partículas estão entrelaçadas. Cada uma delas parece de alguma forma saber instantaneamente o resultado da
medição da outra. Ainda há alguma discordância sobre como exatamente interpretar esse
entrelaçamento e o que acontece quando medimos um estado entrelaçado, mas essas questões são mais filosóficas.
A teoria é bastante inegável neste ponto: o entrelaçamento é definitivamente real, e sabemos isso graças a Bell, à sua
desigualdade e aos muitos físicos que realizaram experimentos para testá-la. Se queres ser contado entre esses
físicos e realizar o teu próprio teste de Bell num computador quântico, não deixa de acessar o módulo da desigualdade de Bell
com link na descrição. Obrigado por assistir e até a próxima!